[Music]
in for science news Oh for science for
science in for science anything should
be okay for no nevermind I'm not gonna
say anything better
all right submitted by Ryu oh he's a
scientist
I don't know that means dragon it does
yeah that's a great name
like you know right from Street Fighter
yeah just that's what I thought of it's
also ants dog's name greatly great name
yeah that's true I is the only writer I
know possessory fire a group of
scientists ate Legos to see how long it
would take to poop them out oh that's
awesome
how do you swallow it cuz it's as big as
my little wages all right you the little
one looks like pill pill pill size like
this Nagle heads exactly what they
swallow it'll a go ahead go ahead
yeah so yellow little dicks
pediatricians decided to see how long it
will take because you know how they do
it's kids and then kids
yeah pediatrician do the [ __ ] wildest
[ __ ] man but don't they need to get kids
are swollen because adult digestion is
different in kids right you thing I'm
like wait that doesn't okay yeah cuz
they gotta have kids swallow them guys
the next best thing true and then they
put a head in and they Cheers I know but
it gives them an estimated amount of
time yeah yeah like the way they do
experiments on rats and and and pigs and
stuff yeah same thing but it's not even
their job being a pediatrician no you're
a medical practitioner they're not
technically a researcher like which
pediatrician know has a bunch of rats in
the back some time up yep
that lollipops they got the mirror on
the forehead and that's it all right
our pediatrician looks nothing like that
nothing like they did in the 30s all
right y'all they also draining blood
from the feet they don't leave leeches
and none of us is wondering maybe you
should switch pediatricians with
executive tyke is good Pedialyte doctors
follow me my go ahead I hope they said
bottoms up one did that's awesome
okay here we go oh she's the easiest
LEGO pieces sometimes need to be brushed
a six-block
she did
[Music]
you can't do it water and you can't say
bottoms up at the bottom doesn't go up
bottoms up is sinking I want you to
prove I don't want to see this I want to
see it come out yeah I want to see all
of it out the butt yeah I want to see it
when it comes out yeah the video is
called the video will be called six
doctors six Lego heads yes Michael heads
to Augusta can we talk about it yeah
well so they did mention in this so the
whole study here they had they reported
it in the Journal of pediatrics and
child health and so they were the
primary goal was to find out how long it
takes to pass through system and they
found that it's about 1.71 days oh so
they had to yeah so the pre ingestion
bowel habit was standardized by the
stool hard hardness and transit score
aka the shat score and so the
participants right they had to find out
the fart score which is a found and
retrieved time that's what their word
they're just pediatricians [ __ ]
around so they did say that one male
pediatrician never found the head in his
stool I would pay money to watch that no
you wouldn't would love it why do you
want to pay for that would you want to
see Legos and poo joe-joe look at me no
it just sounds like a Disney show Legos
and poo no it does it these in poo I
mean a [ __ ] Legos and poo I don't
want to say [ __ ] what
that's prisoners do all the time in jail
they'll swallow like drugs no but I know
what who looks like I don't know what a
Lego improve looks like yeah your dog
your dog eats all kinds of [ __ ] all the
time you've never seen when there's hair
I love talking about poo
let's just talk about poop poop too much
let's move on I do
we always talk about food I would like
this game who told you that was money
involved in it for $500,000 was a
respectable do I stick my mouth on it
has to be a boa strong mouth on that so
my mouth doesn't have to touch the
butthole it has to be like this oh yeah
so my mouth but also my mouth is on the
anus yeah two million nugget I know
you'll die dear don't do that you like
snow five mil you'll die no hepatitis
machine bro there's all kinds of
diseases well improve yeah
waste not doubt if that's throw I'll be
4/5 wrong steel I bet you're suck a dick
numbers hella low then how much would
you say that dick would $50,000 yeah
that's a yes if that pauses too long
that's a good friend deal yeah what
brand would sponsor that no it's gotta
be Millions dude million oh but you're
such a [ __ ] [ __ ] how would you like it
did you guys ever saw the things in your
kid yes I don't like corn things you
shouldn't be oh yeah ever did that I
used to play this game where I would
take this quarter and I would like try
to like [ __ ] like flip it in the end
with my mouth by blowing out on it and
but I opened my mouth and it went into
my throat I almost died
oh yeah and nobody was nobody was home I
was like nine nobody was home but me and
I was like I always dialed it and when
it finally came out I started crying I
was like eight or nine years old it was
pretty stupid I don't know why I thought
that game was fun that's why people have
a lot of kids and it tasted terrible or
you have a lot of kids yeah you know it
takes it absolutely terrible and I
probably got the flu after - I didn't
really think about stuff I remember
looking at it you know like it looks so
delicious
Pluto I want to be played right and it's
so salty and disgusting to cover the
it's the texture yeah and it looks
delicious
I hate the school play-doh the school
play knows really good which is what
Duncan it's like the red ones the
generic it's not all colorful just like
uh it looks like wonder clay looking
like yeah that one was good because uh
my nap caught thingy in preschool was
underneath where they stored it so I
always stick my hand up in the Shelf
after one fell asleep I'll open the zip
lock bag a little piece how do you
remember this how you remember this
you better check tyka all the time yet
that kid is gonna have so don't worry
he's got my genes to Ramona at least one
year and then I could open his mouth
about these things was in it yeah
swallow it
what are you playing with it I didn't
even see it though when did he do it he
likes to just [ __ ] flip these
teething so he likes filling different
textures my favorite part of Anne's
[ __ ] baby shower
obviously Leia but what are you trying
to break the hit the pinata and heating
you a [ __ ] about her neck she was like
oh I love that [ __ ] did you know she was
head banging cuz hanging but she
listened to the dope ass music she was
tired cute little hairy baby anyway yeah
so you know I mentioned that a male
pediatrician couldn't find the toy in
the stool that's when the the report
said that females may be more
accomplished at searching through their
stools and nails well we all know my men
can't find [ __ ] ever okay you had your
what we had your lip gloss and Ikey it
was like it was a he had like coffee or
what is it you had your glitter lip
cause remember it was strawberry it's
the same [ __ ] synergy him out right now
did I pictured bar with a sparkly
[ __ ] lip gloss with the paintbrush
thing all I thought Bart let's do this
[ __ ] the [ __ ] [ __ ] is wrong with you
I know [ __ ] man so we'll finish your
story so because that is uh what is it
chapstick and it was just behind it he's
like behind his coffee he's like where
is it things all the time I loo that I
wrote and everyone's like just move your
[ __ ] coffee bro he's like oh that's
true sometimes I leave the house while
texting and I panic because I feel like
I lost my phone yeah
because I'm used to walking out and
checking my pocket are you doing the
wallet like where it's in a different
pair of pants and you're like oh that's
me every day I lose my wallet every day
but you're like oh no sometimes I lose
my sunglasses I'm looking everywhere
next on my face the whole time I've done
this before like looking for my glasses
and [ __ ] you know what you know what the
problem is when I start thinking is when
I lose things like you ever go to the
[ __ ] you ever go like shopping and
then you go look for your car and when
you start thinking about where your car
is you lose it all in senators going by
feel right just go you just go and walk
and you walk to your car
oh it's an essential yeah you got mental
GPS and if you don't like the Grove or
something if you if you just go by feel
like let's say me and know we're just
talking right and we just we'll just
walk back to the car but if they're like
wait was it this aisle or that aisle
that's floral on that floor we don't go
by feeling the opposite yeah when I
think that's when my life gets ruined
that happens with we're not ruin that
having three without fits like whenever
I'm in a rush and I need to leave I end
up like putting together really cute
outfit but then when I try to do it you
know you overthink I'm like I overthink
it and I'm like work you gotta go with
your gut so you just gonna think about
when it comes to creative [ __ ] I if I
think then I'm [ __ ] but when it comes
to like finding my car I really have to
think so women are more better at
finding yep things but this is different
because Pooh's evolved right but no it's
not because the the lego they are good
at funny [ __ ] always finding [ __ ] to
complain about and the video
[Music]